hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play mr. kitty saves
the world ok not I've been playing a lot
of horror games recently so I want to
take a snice step back so starting to
affect my dreams I'm feet seeing things
out of the corner of my eyes in my own
apartment so I just want to play a nice
relaxing game where I can show you guys
some real commentary into gaming the
insights behind the indie game world so
let's get started
oh yeah ok so obvious what the hell okay
so obviously I was lying before I bought
the haha
what is that I'm getting stuck on
furniture I guess you're not giving me
enough time man just give me more time
to jump over some that's not a mr. kitty
that's not a kitty that I want
preemptively top what 21 one of those
mean I don't know rehab that my job
I'll go y'all set screen
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play mr. kitty
saves the world now I've been playing a
lot of horror Kings recently and they're
starting to affect my life um I can see
things out of the corner of my eyes
I've got nightmares so I just wanted to
take a step back and to play a nice
relaxing in the game with an old-school
feel to it and give you guys a taste of
what real gaming commentary is all about
so let's get
you